i'm now going to spend about half an
hour or so um moving us right up to the
present day with some thoughts that i
hope will flow somewhat naturally from
that long-term perspective and i want to
move on to trying to
do something which
half an hour doesn't really encompass it
but that's what we've got so i have to
make do which is trying to explain some
of the important aspects of the
contradictions
actually that term in chinese
is a really good way to try and
understand the complexity of
what modern china is contemporary china
it is a society that is open but also
highly authoritarian it is a society
that is globalized but also highly uh
keen to throw up walls both virtual and
real in various ways so a whole variety
of complexities about one of the most
important societies on earth in which i
would remind you amongst other things we
see the world's second biggest economy
possibly become the first in a few years
we don't know yet at the moment the
world's largest population uh the
world's second largest military one has
to to say and also of course depending
how you count it something like a fifth
to a quarter of all of humanity within
the territory of the people's republic
of china and when you include diaspora
ethnic chinese communities around the
world one of the most important and
vibrant cultural
uh networks anywhere in the world so
without any further
delay
let's get on to
the man who
amongst other things defines i think
china in the 2020s certainly in terms of
the people's republic of china and that
is of course
the president of china and perhaps
rather more importantly actually the
general secretary of the communist party
of china
and these two picks of xi jinping i
think in some ways a symbolic of the
contradictions the different aspects
that i was talking about the one at the
bottom uh is a picture of him in person
back in 2017
at
davos i don't know how many of you were
there at davos that year i wasn't i have
to confess but maybe some of you were
hanging out
and xi jinping
gave a speech there which is all about
how china was a
globalizing outward looking power that
would in many ways look to uphold the
pillars of international order now very
much he made that speech in january 2017
a time when a gentleman named donald j
trump was about to be inaugurated as
president of the united states so i
think that while he never mentioned his
name most of president xi's comments
were really uh giving the nod to saying
i believe in globalization i believe in
openness unlike that guy in washington
uh and he said something not dissimilar
actually this year virtually at davos in
2021 but of course um i gather that
davos this year was not in fact um held
in
in person i mentioned that because there
we have um at the top level there the um
great hall of the people
and that is of course this hugely
symbolic place where um actually the uh
the great meetings the congresses all of
that uh in the chinese communist
calendar are held over the months years
and decades and that's very different xi
jinping not different person of course
but different message much more about
china's place in the world seeing china
as a place that in some ways is not
globalized and open and all the stuff
that was said at davos but under siege
in many ways trying to be
fighting back against containment from
the united states from the western world
from powers who basically want to see
china fail and
he in this version of the narrative is
about a china which is looking to use
its economic power its military power
its cultural power to push back and
create an alternative chinese uh vision
of course of its place in wider society
but certainly one that is highly
orchestrated and stabilized at home so
inward looking
communist part of china outward looking
communist part of china
different locations beijing and davos
but it's not all about the leader
let me use this if i may to put forward
a little mnemonic which i have written
about and if any of you uh want to look
on online in the journal foreign affairs
i had a piece back in january of this
year which talks about this in more
detail but let me give you a quick
summary of why i think
what's on here on this slide is a useful
way to try and understand the complexity
of china today and i've called it the
china dna model
it's not just supposed to be a kind of
conventional wisdom or cliche because we
said that everything has you know dna
you know asking tough questions is in
the dna of guests at the how light gets
in festival that sort of thing but i
mean something's more specific do we
have any nobel prize-winning biologists
in the audience today okay well that's
good you don't have to be a developer
president to know that if you look at
natural molecule of dna it's made up of
four nucleotides which have the initials
of the chemicals acgt and i've realized
actually that those dna nucleotide
initials are the same as the factors
that i think make up today's china
and they are
authoritarianism consumerism
globalization and technology what do i
mean by those terms authoritarianism
china today
actually really through most of its
communist period but much more
explicitly today has no embarrassment
no kind of awkwardness about saying we
run a different sort of political system
we are we're not a liberal democracy
we're not looking to become a liberal
democracy you can say this is good you
can say this is bad i'm just saying
analytically this is the way that china
is presenting itself these days it does
sometimes make your gesture saying we're
a different type of democracy but that's
a bit like those people who send you
those burgers i think which they say
tastes just like meat i mean that's like
meat as long as it tastes like cabbage
but authoritarianism i think is just a
straightforward actually quite
analytical way to look at the way in
which china projects itself as a state
that looks for a top-down government
that does not look for pluralism in its
system just you know as i say ticking
boxes on that political science model
second point consumerism not consumption
but consumerism sociology not economics
if you look at all the reasons why the
old soviet union never really managed to
fulfill its project
there were a lot of reasons but one of
them was the inability to provide an
attractive consumer-driven lifestyle for
its wider population in the era of
climate emergency we may now be asking a
lot of questions about whether providing
a great consumer lifestyle for millions
of people was necessarily always the
best idea in the wider world but leave
that aside for the moment the point is
that china today has managed to create a
consumerist
aspiration that the soviet union never
managed to do unless you think that uh
driving a trabant or a jiggly while
going along to a restaurant which is
sort of closed for uh uh most of the the
day and only open for about sort of two
hours in the mid afternoon which was
often the fate in the old soviet union
is an attractive consumer lifestyle
today's middle class chinese with you
know their high quality mobile phones
and weekend trips to places like hainan
island and the tropical lifestyle are
clearly living something that all of us
recognize as a consumerist lifestyle and
the chinese communist party is very
upfront about saying we gave you this
this is why you should support us third
one g globalization global ambition
china until a couple of decades ago was
a place that basically kept itself
broadly within its borders not entirely
a huge exporting country of course but
there was a clear distinction between
the two now china has a presence all
over the world in various ways um i mean
some of the obvious elements are its
increasing importance in global
governance that's been highly
controversial during the pandemic in
terms of role at the united nations the
world health organization but whether
it's for good or ill the point is that
china is in the world and very explicit
about wanting to be in the world and
shaping that world that brings us to the
final factor t
technology and that is really the one
that i think almost drives all the
others these days because whether it's
authoritarianism the ability of china to
be able to gather up huge amounts of
data with very little government
controls on what government can find out
about you whether it's consumerism where
people are using you know alipay on a
daily basis and don't even touch bank
notes and haven't done for years and
years
or basically
using huge new developments in
artificial intelligence to change
everything from shopping to the way that
they work in the office or g
globalization if
in a world where in latin america large
parts of sub-saharan africa in southeast
asia huawei zte major chinese tech firms
are providing an infrastructure that
will then provide path dependency for
future development all of these are
aspects of something that wasn't true
25 years ago and is true now which is
that china has become a tech innovator
not
first tier for that i think most people
who work in this area and there are a
lot of them at this festival would
generally say tell me if i'm wrong that
silicon valley still
way outstrips everywhere else in terms
of first tier invention from scratch
that ecology of
stanford university and berkeley and all
these startups um and you know fantastic
weather you know all of this comes
together somehow to create an amazing i
don't know you know people it didn't
take off in massachusetts because it
snows the whole time in the uh the
winter california i assure you that i
don't think it's snowden's about 1952 or
something and china has not managed to
create for a variety of reasons that
first tier innovation at that level of
uh of of of of of game-changing change
but a very high second tier taking
technology that exists and turning into
something quite unique and
transformative that is happening in
shenzhen it's happening in hangzhou it's
happening up in haitian in northwest
beijing and it's going to keep happening
i think for a long time to come so as
dna strands go four pretty powerful ones
i will go as far as to say in human
history and even non-human history i
think
i haven't seen that combination with
that level of power in any other
parallel society that i can think of to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you